Okay and finally, one last way in which we're
going to look at queries involving arrays. So far we've looked
at querying array-valued fields. We've also looked at supplying
a number of values, using the" in" operator, any of
which can be found in a field, and retrieved
documents for which the value of this field matches any
of the values supplied here. We're going to look at
the inverse of" in," and that is the all operator.
So if you remember, with in, the more values
we add, the larger our query target gets. Always the
inverse. In this case, we're specifying an increasingly narrow target.
That is to say, the model uris field, for a
document must contain all of these values, in order to
be retrieved by this query. Let's take a look at
an actual result set. Okay, and we can see that
here, all of our values are found in this document.
As with this one, and this one, so on. So that's the all operator.